Ken cuccinelli is the former deputy DHS
secretary and Center for renewing
America's senior fellow before we get to
the cartels Ken
this would never have happened at a
normal functioning workplace if someone
on the staff sends the boss something
that totally contradicts something
that's happening he doesn't go out there
and continue to lie he tells the truth
and he tells his boss the truth but that
didn't happen what went wrong no it
didn't happen and Jesse let me
anticipate the excuse he's going to say
well I didn't see that email I guarantee
you if if the secretary is headed to a
White House Press Conference and gets an
email from their Communications team two
and a half hours before that email gets
read by the secretary not by somebody
not by his his secretary but by
secretary mayorkas himself I did more
media for president Trump's
Administration than mayorcas does they
don't let him out very often I can tell
you how this process works and I
anticipate that lie is coming but I
would be shocked shocked if he had not
read that before he went up and said
everything you just showed the American
people again he lied through his teeth
and he threw the people he is
responsible for
not just the American people but the
people who work for him and put their
lives on the line under the bus and
um knowingly it wasn't
you know wasn't casual he knew what he
was doing when he did it in my view this
is impeachable yeah absolutely
impeachable act by him yeah this is one
of many forget about the email thing I
mean think about just look at the border
and talk about the Border I mean the
video we just showed those are this
That's Heavy Artillery these these guys
are tacked up they're strapped up this
is a military weaponry right and this is
just a hop skip and a jump from Texas
the United States what do we need to do
here
well we need to take control of the
border and not not Alejandro mayorka's
secure border but really secure it and
at the center for renewing America we've
put out a a an entire list of proposals
about how to go after this problem
specifically with respect to the cartels
I mean the video footage you were
showing very real that that looks like a
war zone not Street crime right and we
believe America needs to have the
strategy of taking back those parts of
Mexico from the cartels and handing them
over to the Mexican Government realize a
lot of Americans don't know this The
Mexican government does not control
about a third of Mexico
and it and it has never controlled all
of its territory and we suffer in the
United States for that because these
quasi-governmental entities these uh
cartels that run parts of Mexico and use
terrorist tactics use that control of
territory to arm themselves train
themselves their bases of operations
they run industries of making fentanyl
heroin and so forth and ship all of it
into the United States where they're
killing over a hundred thousand
Americans a year a year from our
doorstep yep yeah we got to step it up
designate them terrorist organizations
and then make sure Alejandro never sets
foot in the Department of Homeland
Security ever again thank you so much
Ken
Good To Be With You Jesse hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else